hi my name is Patrick I'm an
applications engineer working for volt
from mathcore and I'll be giving a talk
of integrating system Allah
into the vault foreign language okay so
hello everyone my name is Patrick I'm an
applications engineer working for ball
from mathcore and I'm here today to talk
about some new and upcoming features
coming to the Wolfram language that of
system modeling and with me on this talk
rather with me in spirit because he's
back in Sweden where our office offices
are located is multi lens who provided
me with these slides and he's also the
main developer working on integrating
system modeler into the vault from
language and the outline today will be
as follows increase this a bit maybe
like that's a bit much it's this better
okay so I'll start with some motivation
on why we would like to have system
models in the Wolfram language and kind
of what they are and compare it a bit
what we have right now and what we are
changing and then I'll go over how it
works what we can do with it and how you
can create these for yourself so to
start off what are what is system
modeling and why should we care
well in essence you could say that
system modeling is looking at the world
around you and understanding the rules
and all the math behind it that that
governs it you can do this for many
types we like to call them domains but
you can do that for many types of things
such as mechanical systems you look at
course you look at trains or electrical
systems where you look at circuits will
you look at filters analog filters or
radio relays also or things like that
and also within the process industry or
even softer sciences where you can look
at
metabolic systems and your body and
understanding how medicine affects
different parts different parts of such
systems but just for a smaller example
we can take this this table here you
know it's a it says I guess this is one
leg it has a leg it has a certain height
and a certain center of mass and if I
push up on this table I probably
shouldn't do that but if I push up on
the table it might fall off the but it
might tip over over depending on what
kind of force I exert on it and by
understanding all the math and all the
rules behind that we can start to really
get how a table works or rather a stable
one but of course it's much more than
just understanding this table it's also
as as the name implies sister modelling
it's a it's a system of models so we can
see it that's this laptop here that's
standing on the table it pushes down on
the table and the table pushes back up
on it and this is a really simple way
but sometimes easing the reactions can
become very complex and that those are
the kind of things that you can
understand using system all modeling
those are the kind of things that make
us able to describe a car by kind of
looking at the different the different
smaller parts of the course
and seeing how they interact with each
other that's how we can see look at the
certain electrical components and see
how they how they work together to form
an electrical circuit
so besides tables of course here are
some real-world examples of system
modeling you can analyze different
configurations of a spacecraft you could
help with vibration analysis in a you
know you've designed an engine you want
to understand okay will this engine
vibrate or
we do something different that you can
use a system model to understand how
everything will connect together or in
the softer Sciences such as analyze the
metabolism in a drug treatment or even
in education you can give these these
models to students they can interact
with them they can learn something about
the world around them how the rules are
for different things by getting to
interact with for example a table they
can design and change different things
different parameters such as the the
length of the table leg the chain
builder will changing the mass effect
anything will it affect its tip-over
ability and things like that and we gave
a talk I don't know if you saw it
yesterday about this about having system
models in education so that kind of
provided some of the motivation for that
and for the other things such as the
design and analysis part Yanbu God will
be giving a talk tomorrow on system
modeling in industrial applications so
that will provide some more of the
motivation behind this right now I'll
give it I'll go with some more
implementation details of how this will
look in the valle from language so what
is it that's actually new you might add
that I mentioned system modeler a few
times and system modeler both on system
modeler for those of you who aren't
familiar with it is a standalone product
that connects that integrates with the
ball from language and we have this
package called WSM link that lets you
connect with with the with the system
modeler program lets you do different
analysis tasks let you design different
models but now we're moving to still
have that standalone product which we're
moving the functionality of analysis of
design of system models
moving that to be an integrated part of
the vault from language and what this
will allow you to do for example is if
you if you are designing a model in
system modeler then you will be able to
send that model to a co-worker who who
has evolved from language product we are
starting with desktop Mathematica but we
expect other vil from language products
to follow after that then you can send
it to them and they don't need to have a
copy of system model to this to further
increment on that model design or to
analyze it and to play around with it in
essence and since it's getting
integrated this will give it a tight
become tighter with the other workflows
that are in the wall from language and
before I start with this I should
preface this by saying that the the sign
it's not yet finalized so some of the
things I'm showing here it might change
during the course of the development so
of course this is not available in
Mathematica 11.2 but we expect it to
come in a future release so how does it
work well the central object of all of
this is the system model and we can
create we can create a symbolical
representation of this system model
object but with the system model
function and one of the ways to do this
is to use one of the many pre-built
models the thousand or so pre-built
models that are inside of system model
that will come bundle now with the ball
from language and we can call here a
model called inverted pendulum that's in
the system's package so when right now
right now it's connecting to system
modeler because I have a system model
copy system modeler caught me installed
actually
and it will load a few libraries there
are multiple libraries that you can
download for this that gives some
additional modeling functionality so
that's why it takes some additional time
but now we have it here we have the
system model object and we could expand
it to find out more about it if we this
will what will be shown here will depend
what kind of model it is if it's a
runnable example models such as this one
we will get a diagram of that model and
what we see here is an inverted pendulum
it sends out some variables the position
of the pendulum and it's its angular
velocity it sends it back to a control
in your quadratic controller that has
been designed for this and which feeds
an output into a motor which moves the
base of the pendulum and they are object
the objective here is to keep the
inverted pendulum standing straight so
it's a classical control theory problem
now a kid we could ask for some more
information about this model with the
summary property so this here is just
the same model we could and we can't ask
for summary and this could be kind of an
entry point when you want to understand
more about a certain model that you've
been given you'll get the name you'll
get a description you can see if it's a
simulation one of those regions you can
run this right away or if you need to
connect it up with other things in order
to run it and we also usually divide
things into different domains inside of
with a system model so there's a few
different mechanical domain some analog
some digital electronics the block
blocks here they represent the control
system so you can get kind of get an
instant visualization of how this is
divided into different types of
components you can see that it's kind of
a it has mechanics electronics and block
so it's kind of a mechatronics system
with cute ask for the diagram of the
model it's to say oh I showed it up
there but we can get it using the
diagram property of course we get back a
graphics object you can expand that you
can you know do anything that you would
imagine that you can do with a ball from
language grab graphics object might want
to do some computation on that I don't
know what that would be yeah of course
these are just two properties that you
can get you getting get a lot a lot of
other properties that we can see right
here okay so that's kind of what a
system model is how it looks in the
Wolfram language but more importantly
maybe is what we can do with this well
of course it's a model so we want to
simulate it we want to see how it
changes over time and we can do this
straight by right away by calling the
system model plot command and this will
both simulate and give us back a plot
from the model so now it's starting a
simulation and now we get back we've run
this inverted pendulum system where the
object is to have have the pendulum
position to follow of this line here and
it feeds it back into the control system
and you get back a plot like this now
notice they didn't give it any arguments
because here in these models you can
specify a default did the forth plot
which will be shown instantly if you
call the system model plot command we
could also give it to spent a specific
variable that we wanted to want it to
show or another plot name now that is
the shortest way of simulating a model
but oftentimes we want to do more than
this we just we don't just want to
simulate the model we want to try
different things so one of the ways we
could do this is by for example changing
an input in the model so here our load
another system model and this is an
electrical low-pass filter
and it kind of looks like this here we
have an input to the model which comes
in here that's called V VI and an output
to the model so we set a voltage over
this circuit here and we get back
another voltage over from here
and as the name implies this will be a
low-pass filtering of that voltage
signal so we could for example give it
an input such as a time series let me
just see what this looks I don't
actually know what this what this looks
like looks like it looks like this so
this is the input we'll give to this
low-pass filter and then we can call
this system model simulate command using
this system model object we'll simulate
it for a hella long this time series and
we'll set the input to be that time
series we can also do other things such
as change parameters in the model and
here we if I scroll up a bit you'll
notice that we had two kappa based our
icons for different for electrical
capacitors so we can change the
capacitance of those when we simulate
the model so once it tuns once it's done
simulating we'll get back a simulation
data object that we can call give to
system model plot and we'll plot the
input which comes here and then the
output which has been now gone through a
low-pass filter and of course we can
give it another Wolfram language
functions such as sine wave
yeah so one other ways is to we can hope
hover over it here this is one of the
ways and then if we could get a full
list of all the of all the variables or
for example all there that might be a
long list but we could call different
properties in order to find out what
things are named and I think we're
looking at some some other design of how
to actually explore explore these models
deeper right from the vault from
language in right so that kind of things
you can do with it and then we could of
course change the parameter value see
how how changing the capacitance would
affect the filtering so that could be a
way of understanding low-pass filters
now they said another way to do this
more programmatically we can call the
system model parametric simulator oh
that's quite a mouthful but anyway and
we call it sister model parametric
simulate on a system model we give it
something that we want to get out in
this case it's a variable called said
and we give it a parameter that we want
to change now then we get back a
function that we can give that we give a
parameter value and when once we've
given it a value for this parameter a
we'll get back how the variables said
changes over time so then we can put it
in a table like this and try many
different values for for the parameter a
and see how that effects said so and
another thing that we can do is we can
take a system model and we can linearize
it and the reason why we would want to
do this is because a lot of control
theory a lot of signal
processing it relies on having a linear
model of a system and these system
models are very good at both linear
systems but they're also good at
describing nonlinear systems but we
could still get back a linear
approximation of a nonlinear system so
here I guess I've take let's me see what
it was I actually inputted here it looks
like it looks like a DC motor that I
inputted here and when I did that yeah
it has a it's as an input V an output
which is the the speed of the DC motor
shaft here I call I gave it to system or
linearize and we'll get back a
state-space bottle which have been in
the Volt foreign language for quite some
time so there's a lot of things you can
do with this state space model directly
in the Wolfram language you could design
a PD controller that's that controls
this controls this DC motor or a linear
quadratic controller like the first
example I think it's designed using the
same methodology actually we could
actually do the inverse we could take
this we could take this state trace
model put it in create system model and
what this will do is it will give us
back a system model that has this state
space so it has the same input and the
output V and W has those and but it's
linear so it will behave a bit different
from this one but you can still
simulated you connect it up with other
with other system or lock system model
objects so well that's one of the ways
you can create a system model what are
the other ways well one of the things
you can do is you can specify equations
like you normally would in the ball from
language here we're specifying the
equations for a bouncing ball
so we have the velocity of the ball it's
the derivative of the height the
derivative of the velocity is the
gravitational constant we can even
represent things such as when events so
when the height is equal to zero then we
know we're on the ground the ball is on
the ground so then we want it to bounce
up with some certain restitution so we
define that system of equations and then
we use crate system model and give a
parameter value for this restitution and
in the equations and we get back a model
and we could then take this model and we
can simulate it and it will compile it
into it will first convert it into C
code and then compile it into a very
efficient executable so the first time
you do it exactly compiling the next
time it it's much faster so now we're
similar get thing and then we get we can
call it to get back a plot and this is
this is our system of equations of the
bouncing ball now that's not though that
is something that you could have
simulated in foreign language previously
but something you can do with these
system models is connected up with other
things as I talked about systems of
models so here we'll create another one
and we'll use something we will wrap it
in something that's like a shell in in
system model talk with call it partial
models it has some interfaces for other
things to connect with so the Esso here
the interface dot s oh that's called
that single output so here we will have
a output Y that's sine well it's a it's
a function we can simulate it see see
what it does
and then we connected up to other other
system models such as a discreet sampler
so we'll give it will give a list of the
components we want we want the function
that we just created this one up here
and we want a system model of a discrete
sampler and then we can specify
connections we want that the output from
this function here should go to the
input of the discrete sampler and then
we call connect system model components
and we get back it's quite hard to see
but we get back a model that has been
created for us and we can of course
simulate that like the others yes it
will transform it to model like a code
so I can briefly show it I think if I
open up this one no but it's very useful
if you want to do for example
programmatic modeling creations you
wanted to try many different designs for
your model and then you could create a
table which just spits out different
system models and you plug it into
wherever you want it to control and you
can evaluate which one works the best
yes yeah
[Music]
yeah yeah yeah so if you but if you have
the graphical graphical interface thing
you can do some some drag-and-drop
modeling so we're adding some new
functions to move back and forth between
those but so and it will get so for
example if we call system modular on one
of these objects that we could have
created in the vault from language we
could get it here we can modify it and
then we can send send this model to a
colleague which doesn't have system or
Allah will send back will send him back
this object that we are modified and
they could connect him up they could try
different analysis and now this is only
system models without having a copy of
just a modeler right so there's some
explicit actions you can do you can ask
for for example an animation of of the
system if you have a copy of system
modular so then you can get back an
animation of for example the inverted
pendulum here that I showed in the
beginning so this is kind of a 3d
animation of how it looks right I think
skip that one and I'll just plug some of
the other talks we have here so as I
said this if you want some additional
motivation of why you actually would
should do this John will be giving a
talk tomorrow on how to use system Orla
in industry in product development and
so forth and how to use and many of
these things there he will show you will
actually be able to do just from the
from sending it to someone who has a
copy of the Wolfram language right after
that the
the talk on reinforcement learning with
sister modeler where you take a system
model and you use that to train a neural
network so I'm really excited of of
seeing that also in the basement down
here we have a little robotic arm that
we encourage you to come and say hi to
you can move it around and it kind of
shows how you how a model in system
model can be used to to develop things
before you actually put them in in
production